en el último vídeo vimos distintas
maneras de representar la tendencia
central o el promedio de un conjunto de
datos lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo
es ver de qué manera podemos ahora medir
qué tan dispersos están los datos veamos
esto supongamos que tenemos el siguiente
conjunto de datos menos 10
20 y 30 ese es un conjunto de datos
también tenemos otro conjunto de datos 8
9 10 11 y 12
para empezar calculemos la media
aritmética para ambos conjuntos de datos
calculemos entonces la media y conforme
avances en tus cursos de estadística vas
a entender la diferencia entre la media
de una población y la media de una
muestra estamos suponiendo que estos
datos corresponden a una población y que
estos datos también corresponden a una
población así es que lo que vamos a
calcular son medias de población
calcularemos directamente los parámetros
de la población
estamos tomando en cuenta todos los
datos de esa población en ocasiones vas
a calcular estadísticos a partir de
muestras para estimar parámetros de la
población por lo pronto no nos
preocupemos de eso lo quería dejar en
claro para aquellos que van a
profundizar en el estudio de la
estadística ahora la media poblacional
la media aritmética de este conjunto de
datos es menos 10 + 0 + 10
20-30 dividido entre 5 y esto cuánto nos
da este menos 10 se cancela con este 10
nos queda 20 30 y 50 sobre 5 esto es
igual a 10 y para este otro conjunto de
datos la media es 8 9 10 11 12
todo esto dividido sobre 5 hagamos la
suma de la siguiente manera sumamos este
8 + 12 20 9 + 11 otros 20 20 20 40 10
son 50 sobre 5 esto es igual a 50 sobre
5 que es igual a 10 así es que las dos
medias de la muestra en perdón las dos
medias poblacionales son iguales a 10
bueno si no te quieres preocupar de si
son de población o de muestra podemos
decir que en ambos casos las medias
aritméticas son iguales a 10 si sumas
estos números y los divides entre 5 y si
sumas estos números y los divides entre
5 en ambos casos obtienes 10 pero
claramente estos dos conjuntos de datos
son
con tan solo ver estos números podrías
pensar que los dos conjuntos son iguales
al observar los dos conjuntos de datos
hay algo que llama la atención todos
estos números están muy cerca de 10 el
mayor de ellos está tan solo a dos
unidades de 10-12 eeuu de 10 en cambio
al ver estos números están bastante
alejados de 10 los más cercanos a 10
están a 10 unidades y los más alejados
están a 20 unidades este conjunto de
datos está más disperso más disperso
estos números de aquí están más alejados
de su media que estos números de aquí de
su media veamos ahora cómo podemos medir
esta dispersión o qué tan lejos se
encuentran en promedio un conjunto de
datos con respecto a su media una manera
de calcular esto digamos la manera más
simple es el rango y no es un valor que
se usa comúnmente pero es una manera muy
simple de evaluar dispersión simplemente
calculando la diferencia entre el valor
máximo y el valor mínimo así es que para
este conjunto es 30 que es el máximo
menos el valor mínimo
-10 esto es igual a 40 es decir para
este conjunto de datos el rango la
diferencia entre el valor mínimo y el
valor máximo es igual a 40 para este
otro conjunto de datos el rango es el
máximo 12 menos el mínimo 8 lo cual es
igual a 4 en este caso el rango es una
buena medida de dispersión cuando
calculamos la media
vimos que para ambos conjuntos de datos
está es igual a 10 sin embargo para este
conjunto de datos encontramos un rango
mucho mayor
indicándonos que son datos más dispersos
sin embargo en general el rango no es
una buena medida de dispersión pudiera
ser que tuviéramos dos conjuntos de
datos con el mismo rango y sin embargo
la distribución de los valores la
variación que tiene los valores con
respecto a la media ser totalmente
distinta ahora la medida más usada para
dispersión es la varianza la varianza de
hecho en realidad la más usada es la
desviación estándar aquí vamos a hablar
de la desviación estándar que está
íntimamente relacionada con la varianza
el símbolo para la varianza y de nueva
cuenta estamos suponiendo que estos son
datos de una población son
los datos que están en la población no
es una muestra no es un subconjunto de
la población entonces el símbolo para la
varianza de la población es esta letra
sigma elevada al cuadrado sigma al
cuadrado representa la varianza de la
población y veremos que la sigma sin el
cuadrado representa la desviación
estándar hay una razón para ello
pero en fin la definición de la varianza
es la siguiente vamos a tomar cada uno
de nuestros datos ya ese valor le vamos
a restar la media vamos a elevar al
cuadrado esa diferencia y vamos a tomar
el promedio de esas diferencias
recordemos que para este conjunto de
datos la media es de 10 iniciamos el
cálculo con este valor de menos 10
déjame bajar un poquito mi pantalla para
hacerlo aquí abajo así es que el primer
valor es menos 10 menos la media menos
10 elevado al cuadrado este es el primer
valor de menos 10 y le estoy restando la
media de 10 luego al cuadrado y le voy a
sumar el siguiente valor que es 0 menos
aquí está la media de 10 aquí está la
media de 10 que tenemos elevado al
cuadrado más 10 menos 10 elevado al
cuadrado es este 10 que tenemos aquí más
el siguiente valor que es 20 menos 10
elevado al cuadrado y finalmente más 30
menos 10 elevado al cuadrado estos que
acabamos de escribir aquí son los
cuadrados de las diferencias entre cada
dato y la media esta que tenemos aquí es
la media esta es la media estoy
encontrando la diferencia entre cada
dato y la media elevando al cuadrado
cada diferencia sumando los para obtener
entonces el promedio de las diferencias
elevadas al cuadrado dicho así suena
complicado pero lo único que he hecho es
tomar cada uno de los datos sacar su
diferencia con respecto a la media
elevada al cuadrado y voy a sacar el
promedio dividiendo entre 1 2 3 4 5
dividiendo entre 5 y esto a que es igual
bien tenemos aquí menos 10 menos 10 es
menos 20 elevado al cuadrado sería 400
más
0 - 10 menos 10 se eleva al cuadrado más
100 más 10 menos 1000 elevado al
cuadrado es 0 más 2010 es 10 elevado al
cuadrado es 100 más 30 menos 10 20
elevado al cuadrado 400 todo eso
dividido entre 5 y esto cuánto nos da
400 más 100 son 500 más otros 500 esto
es igual a 1000 sobre 5 y esto es igual
a 200 así es que para este conjunto de
datos la varianza es igual a 200 esta es
nuestra medida de dispersión comparemos
ahora este valor con la varianza de este
otro conjunto de datos de este otro
conjunto de datos que aparentemente está
menos disperso voy a hacerlo por acá
oops ahí se me acabó el espacio mejor
voy a irme hacia arriba aquí tenemos un
poco más
voy a calcular entonces la varianza de
este conjunto de datos recordemos que la
media es igual a 10 la varianza es
entonces la varianza es igual a 8 menos
10 elevado al cuadrado más 9 menos 10
elevado al cuadrado más 10 menos 10
elevado al cuadrado más 11 menos 10 me
voy a subir un poco más 11 menos 10
elevado al cuadrado más 12 menos 10
elevado al cuadrado
todo eso lo voy a dividir entre entre 5
que es el número de diferencias al
cuadrado que tenemos 5 voy a calcular
entonces la varianza esto es igual a 8
menos 10 menos 2 elevado al cuadrado
cuatro más nueve menos diez menos uno
elevado al cuadrado uno más diez menos
diez elevado al cuadrado cero más 11
menos diez uno elevado al cuadrado uno
más doce menos diez es 2 elevado al
cuadrado
4 todo eso dividido entre 5 y esto
cuánto nos da aquí tenemos 4 15 5 10
sobre
esto es igual a 2 así es que la varianza
aquí déjame checar si serían los
cálculos si efectivamente está bien
calculado la varianza para este conjunto
de datos menos disperso la varianza es
igual de acuerdo a lo que acabamos de
calcular la varianza es igual a 2 y esto
nos confirma que efectivamente este
conjunto de datos es menos disperso que
este otro conjunto de datos ahora el
problema con la varianza es tenemos los
datos tomamos las diferencias de estos
datos con respecto a la media las
elevamos al cuadrado y las sumamos y
esto nos da un número que es un tanto
arbitrario pues estamos tratando con
magnitudes físicas digamos que por
ejemplo estas son distancias estos
serían por ejemplo menos 10 metros 0
metros 10 metros acá tendríamos 8 metros
y cuando elevada al cuadrado obtendrías
unidades extrañísimas como metros
cuadrados unidades que no hacen sentido
es por eso que generalmente se prefiere
en vez de usar la varianza como medida
de dispersión usar la desviación
estándar
desviación desviación estándar la cual
se define simplemente como la raíz
cuadrada de la varianza la raíz cuadrada
de la varianza es decir la raíz cuadrada
de sigma cuadrada y el símbolo para la
desviación estándar es simplemente sigma
ahora que ya hemos calculado la varianza
para los dos conjuntos de datos es muy
fácil calcular la desviación estándar la
desviación estándar del primer conjunto
de datos va a ser igual sigma va a ser
igual a la raíz de 200 que es igual a la
raíz de 2 por 100 que es igual a 10 raíz
de 2 ahora para el segundo conjunto de
datos la varianza la calculamos igual
sacamos la raíz cuadrada del perdón la
alineación estándar es la raíz cuadrada
la varianza la desviación estándar para
el segundo conjunto de datos es igual a
la raíz de 2 y aquí vemos que la
desviación estándar del segundo conjunto
de datos es la décima parte de la
desviación estándar del primer conjunto
de datos
este es 10 raíz de dos y este
simplemente raíz de dos así es que esto
es
a veces
diez veces
desviación estándar 10 veces la
desviación
estándar y esto qué quiere decir que
significa que la desviación estándar del
primer conjunto de datos equivale a 10
veces la desviación estándar del segundo
conjunto de datos recordemos cómo
calculamos la varianza para cada dato
calculamos que tan lejos estaba de la
media lo elevamos al cuadrado y tomamos
el promedio de esos valores luego
sacamos raíz cuadrada para tener
unidades aceptables y concluimos que el
primer conjunto de datos tiene 10 veces
la desviación estándar del segundo
conjunto de datos veamos ahora los dos
conjuntos de datos hemos encontrado que
este conjunto de datos tiene 10 veces 10
veces la desviación estándar desviación
estándar lo cual hace sentido
intuitivamente ambos tienen una media de
10 pero aquí el 9 está a una distancia
del 10 y aquí está el 0 a diez de
distancia del 10 8 está solo a 2
mientras que menos 10 está a 20
comparativamente cada uno de los datos
está 10 veces más lejos de la media
vemos entonces que la desviación
estándar tiene significado más claro de
que tanto en promedio se alejan los
datos con respecto a la media
espero que esto te sea útil